hi this is dr. Gregory Sadler I'm a
professor of philosophy and the
president and founder of an educational
consulting company called reason IO
where we put philosophy into practice
I've studied and taught philosophy for
over 20 years and I find that many
people run into difficulties reading
classic philosophical texts sometimes
it's the way things are said or how the
text is structured but the concepts
themselves are not always that
complicated and that's where I come in
to help students and lifelong learners
I've been producing longer lecture
videos and posting them to youtube many
viewers say they find them useful what
you're currently watching is part of a
new series of shorter videos each of
them focused on one core concept from an
important philosophical text I hope you
find it useful as well in his short
piece the crowd is untruths Erwin
Kierkegaard is speaking a little bit
hyperbolically but he makes it very
clear that what he's talking about is
not any sort of truth like for example
that there are words on the chalkboard
or that you're watching or listening to
this but rather all the things that fit
into what he at one point in this essay
calls the religious spiritual and
intellectual domains everything that has
to do with something of fundamental
value or as he'll call it a little bit
later with the eternal and he wants to
say that those sorts of things cannot be
left up to the crowd the crowd cannot be
as he says the court of last resort you
can't ballot them whether you're doing
so with clickers in the classroom or
people texting into American Idol or
having a proposal and a referendum or
anything like that when it comes to the
things that fundamentally matter that
cannot be dealt with in that way the
crowd is inevitably going to be untruth
and untruth is not simply falsity it
stands in the way of any possible access
to something that would in fact be truth
now what are the the domains that he's
going to discuss and why is this such a
problem so the crowd by appealing to it
by by making that the the hallmark the
center the value of one's existence you
lose touch with God the eternal and you
lose touch with yourself as the what he
calls the single individual you're not
really treating yourself as an
individual you're treating yourself as
simply part of a crowd so he tells us at
one point that what ends up happening
through this dynamic is that it makes
individuals unrepentant they don't think
that they're doing anything wrong when
they do something wrong when they say
they've got something you know that it
is right but they're actually doing the
wrong thing they're in error and they
they won't admit it they won't deal with
that they also become irresponsible
because who are they in fact responsible
to and in what way are they responsible
if they're just members of a crowd
rather than individuals who can be held
responsible he says that there's a
lessening of responsibility they end up
being treated as just one of many and he
gives you examples of this he says a
crowd you know either renders the single
individual this way or weakens his
responsibility by making it a fraction
of his decision a crowd will do things
that the individuals themselves would
not feel all right in doing or perhaps
in even considering so he associates it
in general this this notion of the crowd
with three main things and they all
start with P in the English language
politics or politicians now we have to
point out that that Kierkegaard does see
a legitimate domain in which politicians
can operate and you know decisions can
be made about those sorts of things
quite legitimately and then there's
he calls the public and the press which
he talks more about in in other works
but which he mentions here so if we look
at what he has to say about politics he
says that you know the the person who
actually yeah there's no one who has
more contempt for what it is to be a
human being than those who make it their
profession to lead the crowd let's
summon some individual human beings
certainly approach such a person what
does he care about him
that is too small a thing he proudly
sends them away
there must be at least a hundred and if
there are thousands then he bends before
the crowd vows and scrapes what untruth
now are all politicians like this no of
course there are plenty who you know
listen to individuals and decide to fix
the pothole that you came to see the
alderman about and they you know care
about you and they get involved and but
that means that they're not acting like
other politicians they're not doing the
usual thing of politics which is to see
what as many people think or to assemble
them all together and make decisions on
that basis so politicians in general
lead and address the crowd and he says
they address the crowd as the court of
last resort meaning that they you know
if push comes to shove as we say if you
have to make a decision you go with what
the larger number or at least some
number are going to say is the right
thing now he says of course that that
which in politics and similar domains
which would be you know the marketplace
perhaps educational institutions has its
validity sometimes wholly sometimes in
part becomes untruth when it is
transferred to the intellectual
spiritual and religious domains so he
says I will add that by truth I mean
eternal truth but politics and the like
has nothing to do with eternal truth
politics can't determine any of these
sorts of questions
you don't let politics decide
intellectual matters the intellectual
matters should be decided on their own
basis you don't let politics decide
religious matters you don't let it
decide spiritual matters according to
Kierkegaard so what else do we have
going on here there's what he calls the
public and this is something that
Kierkegaard devotes a lot of discussion
to in many different works he says that
this is something fairly new and he and
he's right about this because one of the
things that other theorists have have
looked at and talked about at great
length is the development in modernity
of what we call the public sphere as
opposed to other ways of looking at
things politically and the appeal to
publicity or public opinion and saying
you know what would the people think
about this or what will they say what
will people have to say if for example
we put this out on the internet you know
and and we're in a time of hyper
publicity ourselves this kind of ties
together with the press that we're gonna
look at in a moment but first let's talk
about this notion of the public he says
that it's an abstraction it's a it's a
crowd but it's not a crowd of
individuals that you can identify and
say ah that's the guy from down the
street
ah that's the guy from the town over
there oh there's my professor oh there's
there's my grocer or anything like that
instead the public is this amorphous
abstract not quite entity you can't even
say that it has true being or existence
but it exerts an important effect within
modern societies so he says here we go
the crowd is untruth I could weep in
every case I can learn to long for the
eternal when I think about our ages
misery even compared to the ancient
world's greatest misery in that the
daily press and anime
to make our age even more insane with
help from the public which is really an
abstraction which makes a claim to be
the court of last resort in relation to
the truth so that's where this you know
the Bucks stopping here is but there is
no place for the buck to stop so there's
always somebody who's speaking for or
representing the public but you never
actually know what the public is and it
becomes this force that we kowtow to
that we you know take into account we we
get worried about the public and what
they're going to think of us unless we
have the capacities to to resist those
temptations he goes on a little bit
further and he says assemblies which
make this claim surely do not take place
there's never any point where the entire
public is assembled and yet this is
something that we fear something that we
can feel oppressed by something that we
can also appeal to and sort of ride as
we would on the crest of a great wave
lifting us up look at all the likes I've
got on Facebook or in YouTube or pick
whatever you you want that's an appeal
to a certain kind of public that's a
tangible although rather abstract
because it's just you know computer you
know code really but there's something
you can actually look at on the screen
that's a somewhat more concrete way of
representing the public but then it can
turn against you in all sorts of thumbs
downs or dislikes or anything like that
and he says that this this public is
anonymous it ultimately is no one so he
says in ancient times the relatively
unrepentant crowd was the Almighty of
all these people gathered together
shouting and doing terrible things right
but in the present in the modern age
he says that now there is the absolutely
unrepentant thing no one an anonymous
person the author an anonymous person
the public sometimes even anonymous
subscribers therefore no one no one and
so this is part of the condition of the
crowd of modern times this is why in all
these matters of religious spiritual
intellectual significance
the crowd is untruth then he talks about
a little bit here the press he doesn't
go into great detail about it what role
does the press play the press you might
say is where the public attains some of
its representation does so also in the
political sphere politicians can make
you no recourse to the public that can
claim to speak for it but the press in
modern times the Fourth Estate as we
often call it is the place where this
anonymity of the public gets presented
public opinion is against this
politician public opinion is against
this religious doctrine public opinion
is for this intellectual development
this is progressive this is not
progressive this is you know good and
conservative this is not all that is the
press in one form or another whether
it's a printing press or whether it's
somebody doing a podcast or it's
somebody posting things on Facebook or
all the other you know types of
traditional media that that have their
their fingers everywhere else and all
interconnect with each other all of
those are ways in which the crowd speaks
itself and speaks to itself and can suck
in the individual who is not wary who is
not keeping themselves apart from it in
all of these there is untruth at least
in the respect that Kierkegaard is
talking about we're talking about
eternal truth things that really really
matter
none of these politicians the public the
press the way they care
understands them the way that he depicts
them here none of them can actually
understand or articulate or embody the
truth
you